está construida dentro del gran salón
del palacio de justicia más histórico de
francia en esta sala de audiencias se
llevará a cabo el juicio en contra de
los acusados de participar en los
atentados de parís de noviembre del 2015
45 metros de largo 15 metros de ancho la
estructura temporal de gran tamaño costó
10 millones de euros no habría sido
posible albergar este juicio en una de
nuestras salas de audiencia existentes
en condiciones adecuadas nunca hemos
tenido tantas víctimas en un juicio
terrorista no hubiéramos podido acoger
los de manera digna tuvimos que
construir esta sala de audiencias para
garantizar el mejor desarrollo posible
del juicio 1800 víctimas han presentado
demandas civiles e incluyen a los
sobrevivientes de los ataques y los
familiares de los fallecidos más de 300
abogados nos representarán en el sistema
de justicia francés estos demandantes
civiles participan en las audiencias del
juicio penal de los 14 acusados 11 de
ellos se encuentran en prisión y se
sentarán en este espacio fuertemente
custodiado hay tres de los acusados que
están en libertad condicional ellos se
sentarán en cambio en esas sillas justo
ante el proceso será grabado en vídeo
esas imágenes irán al archivo judicial y
por primera vez habrá una emisión en
directo del sonido de la audiencia para
los demandantes que no vengan aquí hasta
el palacio de justicia en este despacho
de abogados de parís la juristas amia
maktub preparan 40 demandas civiles
interpuestas por las víctimas
el fixing piojo que son las víctimas a
las que represento esperan quizás
obtener algunas respuestas porque hasta
el día de hoy no entienden por qué
sucedió con cajasur poco a zdf esto
podría haber hecho algo más para
prevenir este desastre off y despejamos
de response
un proceso que se espera se extienda
hasta fines de mayo del próximo año